hello baby
[Applause]
will you read us a bedtime story okay
okay three little kittens with Fleur all
brushed said we can't sleep we feel too
rushed wow this is garbage do you
actually like this illumination the
studio that brought you Despicable Me
The Secret Life of pets
Phil heroic and handsome
I'm a little wet but I still look good
the Grinch
You're a Mean One Mister sing
you okay
oh yes I'm fine thank you
how are you minions
[Music]
[Applause]
and the Super Mario Brothers movie
there's a huge Universe out there
this Christmas illumination brings you a
film for the entire family
here we go tail feather torsion check
Wing deployment
let's fly
migration
We're not gonna make it early Uncle Dan